[MUSIC PLAYING]
LUKE DAVIS: Welcome
to "Assistant On Air,"
where we talk to the experts
behind the Google Assistant.
I'll be your host
today, Luke Davis,
an engineer who works on
the Actions on Google team.
I build tools for developers.
And I'll be interviewing my dear
friend, Jessica Dene Early-Cha.
Jessica, why don't you tell
everybody about yourself?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: So
I'm a Developer Advocate
for Google Assistant.
So I sit right across from you.
So I get to work with you
all day, which is exciting.
But a lot of what I do is
I get to be able to build
actions for Google Assistant.
And so I build out
functionalities and different
experiences that users can have.
And by doing that, I learn
more about the product.
And if I see anything
that's not going well,
be able to tell the product
team, the engineers who
are building it.
And then I get to build out
contents like blogs and videos
like this and share that
out to the community,
and be able to go and meet
with other developers,
hear their feedback of,
like, what's not going right.
And then I could
grab that and then
take that feedback in and
give it to the product team
so we can make our
product better.
LUKE DAVIS: So you're
like an ambassador
between the developer community.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Yeah,
I like to think of that.
Yeah, totally.
LUKE DAVIS: --and the rest
of the engineering team.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Between both.
Yeah, so it's a nice little--
it's an interesting space,
because of course, you're
so close to the product
that you know the ins and outs.
But because you're
so close, it's
hard to see those blind spots.
And so it's nice to like,
OK, let me go and meet
with actual people who
are working on this
and be able to feel like,
oh, that doesn't make sense,
or this makes sense, or maybe
this is a better option,
and be able to get that
and make it better.
So it's amazing space.
LUKE DAVIS: That sounds
like the most fun job ever.
You're just like,
you make cool things,
talk to a couple of people.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Totally.
LUKE DAVIS: Do you have a
thing that you can show us?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Oh,
my gosh, so I've recently
been building an action that's
all about supporting developers
on kind of learning how to
practice for whiteboarding--
technical whiteboarding
interviews.
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah, yeah.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: And
so I could definitely
show you how to do this.
And so I'm going to activate it.
Hey, Google, talk to
whiteboarding practice.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Sure.
Let's get
whiteboarding practice.
[CHIME]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GOOGLE ASSISTANT:
Welcome back, Jessica.
Let's get ready to do some
whiteboarding challenges.
I can give you
random challenges.
Are you--
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: So pretty
much is it activated my action,
and then it talks to you.
And so I can have a
conversation with it
and ask it for whiteboarding
problems that are hard or easy.
And then I could, in real time,
be able to get a whiteboard
and try to solve those problems.
LUKE DAVIS: That is so sweet.
Did you actually have to
record the audio for that?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: No.
So what's really great is
it makes it super easy,
where it's just text--
LUKE DAVIS: Oh, wow.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: --that
I send to Google Assistant,
and Google Assistant will
translate that text to speech.
So I'm not actually
having to handle
all of the voices and the
audio, which is really nice.
LUKE DAVIS: Really?
Well, I thought I
heard, like, a ukulele
or something in the background.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Yeah.
Yeah, there's a little
bit of music on there.
So I'm using what's called SSML,
which is Synthetic Speak Markup
Language.
LUKE DAVIS: OK.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
And you can add audio,
and you could add,
like, silly voices.
You can even have it where
it's layered to really create
a rich experience for users.
LUKE DAVIS: Oh, how neat.
So help me understand what's
actually happening here.
We've got this phone.
I assume you can do the same
thing on, like, a Google Home.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Oh, totally.
Yeah, I'm going to be
on the Google Home,
meaning there's headphones.
Gosh, there's smart displays.
There are so many
different devices
that support Google Assistant.
LUKE DAVIS: Cool.
So the user talks to the
phone or the Google Home,
and they say, I want to talk
to Jessica's awesome app.
And then somehow, some
code that you wrote
gets executed and then
return to the user.
So can you kind of
walk me through what's
actually happening there?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
Totally, yeah.
So when the user
says the activation,
to talk to the action's name,
Google Assistant will hear that
and will figure out
what do they mean,
if that is something that's
being explicitly triggered,
which means its actual name.
Or they might be
able to say something
like, I want to
practice whiteboarding
for technical interviews--
could potentially trigger this
as well.
And so Google Assistant will
figure that out and then
surface it to the user.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Mm-hmm.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
And that's when
it pings my code in my back
end, and like, hey, somebody
is asking for your
device, for your action.
And that's where I would
surface the welcome greeting,
like, hey, welcome to my action.
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah, yeah.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: And so
there's that back and forth
dialog that happens.
And that's something
that it could
be built in multiple ways.
The way I built this one was
using a tool called Dialogflow.
LUKE DAVIS: OK, tell
me about Dialogflow.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
Yeah, so Dialogflow--
because you can imagine.
People are-- we're
all a little funky.
We all see things
a little weird.
I know I'm not the best when it
comes to speaking well English.
[LAUGHTER]
And so there's people like me
out there that can make it--
it can be a little
harder to write
a regular expression, trying to
bring out what I actually mean.
LUKE DAVIS: Oh, yeah.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
Imagine having
to handle different ways
someone might ask for something.
LUKE DAVIS: That
would be a nightmare.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Right.
And so Dialogflow, what that
does, it uses machine learning,
and it becomes my natural
language processor.
And so what we could do with
Dialogflow is I feed in--
if somebody says something
like this, this, and this,
for it to hit my back end
and this part of my code.
And so for this
example, I have it
where if somebody says something
like, give me a challenge,
give me a random challenge, or
a hard challenge, or a question,
it hits my back end for
code that says, ask problem.
And then from there, I
go to look up my database
on the problem I
want to give them,
send that back to
Dialogflow, which
sends it to Google Assistant.
And this is all text.
And Google Assistant
translates that text to speech,
sends it to the device.
And then the user gets it.
LUKE DAVIS: How cool.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: And that
happens all real quick.
LUKE DAVIS: So you don't
have to be a machine learning
expert or anything like that.
The Dialogflow platform
is what gives you this--
I don't know what to
think about this--
like a machine learning-powered
regular expression almost?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
Yeah, it's amazing.
It's such a great tool.
Because again, you
don't have to learn
and have to know everything.
You just have to be thoughtful
on the types of training
phrases you give it.
LUKE DAVIS: Training phrases.
OK, yeah.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
And making sure
that those training
phrases fit within what
your expectations are.
And I like to think
of creating-- they're
called intents in Dialogflow.
And I like to think of it
like the functionality,
like what type of options do
I want to provide to my users.
Like, what's the
functionality part.
And to trigger
that functionality,
that's the training phrases
that the user will say.
LUKE DAVIS: I see.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: And
so when they say that,
triggers that functionality,
which triggers my code,
and my code will
respond appropriately.
LUKE DAVIS: OK, and
so in a lot of ways,
it's almost like a GET
request to an Express server
or something like that.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
Totally, yeah.
I like to think of it
definitely like when
it comes to, like, web
requests, you could definitely
think of it as a resource
that you're just asking for.
And so imagine having instead
of tons of different resources
available, you could use machine
learning to just have one,
and that if anyone says
a variation of that,
it triggers that one.
LUKE DAVIS: How neat.
Can the Dialogflow
platform pull details out
of the user's speech?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
That's a great question.
Yeah.
So it can.
They're called entities.
And what happens there
is for this example,
again, if someone
asks for a question,
I'll give them a
random question.
But if they say, I
want an easy question,
I should give them an
easy question, right?
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah, yeah.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: And so you
could pull those out and then
be able to use that in my code.
So with Dialogflow, you can
have that be required or not.
And so if someone
doesn't give it to me,
and I say it's required,
Dialogflow will respond back,
hey, what type of
level do you want?
And you could code
that yourself.
Or you give the
option like I have,
where if they gave
it to me, great.
If they don't, I'll do random.
LUKE DAVIS: How neat.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
And so it depends
on how you want to
handle it as a developer.
LUKE DAVIS: That's
super, super cool.
It sounds like there are
tons of different services.
Like, you mentioned your phone
and the actual Google Home
itself.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Yeah.
LUKE DAVIS: Like, how do
you build your application
to accommodate both
of those things?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Totally.
And this is where it
gets really interesting.
Because when you're
building, we generally
recommend build a voice first.
Build it as though there's
no screen, so that way,
you're actually building
for the conversation.
And that is, in my opinion,
one of the hardest parts.
And so if you
could focus on that
and have a really
good experience
when it's just voice only, that
means when you have things--
I have screens, like your
phone, or smart displays,
or other elements, then you
could add and enrich those
using visuals to it.
So that way, on the
different devices
that are available for Google.
So soon you could
have those options.
And as a developer, you can
know whether they have a screen
or if they don't have a screen.
So then you can be able to give
the different experiences based
off of the device
that the users have.
LUKE DAVIS: Own it.
So how far can I push this?
Like, can I do other stuff, like
maybe an image or something?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Totally.
Yeah.
So when it comes to
the visual components,
we have, of course,
images and buttons.
And those little
button things are
called suggestion chips, which
is a great design element.
So let's say if you're my user
and I ask you a question--
and there's kind of
common responses--
instead of you having to
figure out and think about it,
I could just have
a suggestion chip.
That way, it's easier
for you to just be like,
yeah, that option.
That's what I like.
Or if I have something
that has account linking
and I know something about you,
that your favorite color is
blue, I could always make sure
I offer you blue things instead
of other things too.
And so you have that level
of customize experience
for your users too.
LUKE DAVIS: What if I wanted
to make, like, a little robot
and put the Google
Assistant in it?
Or want to make some kind of,
like, cool art installation
and make it, like,
voice interactive?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Yeah.
Oh, gosh.
First thing I'm thinking
about is Smart Home.
LUKE DAVIS: OK.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: So
if you want something
where you're kind of
integrating into the IoT space,
you totally can, which
is really exciting.
One of my coworkers
recently found
a ball that moves on its own.
LUKE DAVIS: OK.
Like a little spherical
robot or something?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
Like a little sphere.
Yeah.
And it just rolls around.
And he connected that to
an action he built out.
And so he has two little girls.
And his little
girls tell the ball
to move forward really fast
or for a long distance.
And so they can control the
ball with just their voice,
which is adorable.
LUKE DAVIS: That's adorable.
Oh, my gosh.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
So you can do a lot
of really cool integration.
And then something
that I do at my home
is I don't touch light
switches anymore.
I just tell Google Assistant
to turn off my lights
in the master bedroom
or all the lights.
I even have it to
where I have routines,
which is a Google Assistant
feature, where I can just
tell Google, I'm going
to bed or good night.
And it will turn off
all the lights for me,
which is really nice.
LUKE DAVIS: That's awesome.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Yeah.
LUKE DAVIS: So I
assume that you were
doing other kinds of engineering
before you got into this crazy,
like, voice conversation world.
Like, what are the
lessons that you
have had to pick up
in this new space
that you didn't have
necessarily coming
from web or mobile
development background?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Definitely.
Something that
whenever I do a talk,
I usually tell people--
because I want people
to learn from my mistakes.
I'm definitely one
of those people,
like, I've done this
mistake, please don't do it.
It's not worth the time
to suffer through this.
So something I did that was
horrible was I went to the docs
and I was reading.
And the first thing was
like, make a design just
on your conversation.
And I was like,
skip, skip, skip.
Because I wanted
to get to the code.
Because I'm a developer.
I want to actually
build something.
And as I was doing that,
I realized, oh, crap.
I don't know what I'm doing.
And it's not the technical part.
It's not the actually be
able to query my database
to generate a response.
Like, that stuff
is basic coding.
That's not the hard part.
It's the designing
the conversation.
And at any point, the user could
say something totally random.
LUKE DAVIS: Mm-hmm.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: And
that's how people are.
And how do you code it so
it can handle that and guide
the user through it?
And so when it comes to mobile
development or web development,
as a developer, you
have a lot of control.
This is my image.
This is a screen.
This is the page you see.
And these are the
buttons you have.
And that's it.
When it comes to
conversation, you
have to release a
lot of that control
and allow your user to figure
out where the boundaries are
and guide them to what options
you have that's possible.
LUKE DAVIS: That seems like
such a different frame of mind
than what I do when
I'm building a web app.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Totally.
Totally.
LUKE DAVIS: So how
do you do that?
Like, if you were actually
to not hit the skip,
skip, skip and so the
conversation design thing,
what does that
actually look like?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Totally.
So I had to do that.
And now, whenever
I meld any action,
that's the first thing I do.
A nice easy way-- there's
tons of documentation
that helps you.
But something I
really like to go into
is, I love to get people and
go, OK, you are the action
and this is what you do.
And I like to get someone
else, you're the user.
And then have the
conversation and be
able to write it out down.
That way I can see how people
might say something different.
And then what I like
to do after that,
get a little bit of a
sample, it's turn around,
get two other new random
people, you're this,
this is what you are, and
then just document that down.
And that usually gives
me a nice base of like,
oh, this is kind of how
people talk about this concept
and they might navigate
through things.
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah.
Yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And so that's
one way that's really easy
to be able to build out,
but by all means, there's
so much documentation
that you could get,
that's out there,
that really helps support this.
But it is kind of hard to get
something that's not visual
and make it, write it
down, have a visual,
because again, the conversation
could go anywhere at any point.
So that's just a starting ground
to at least get you going.
And then after that you start
realizing, oh, people actually
want you to repeat yourself
every once in a while.
So that's something that
you would want to have,
I think, in every action,
to be able to have
that functionality.
So you start noticing some
common practices from there.
LUKE DAVIS: OK.
So what sorts of
things are-- like
you just said that
repeating things
is kind of the
common functionality
that lots and lots of people
might want in their action.
Am I getting the
terminology right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yes.
LUKE DAVIS: OK.
What sorts of things are built
into kind of help developers
along the path of making these
things a little bit easier?
Am I going to have to
write my own account
linking software or
asking for location
software, that sort of thing?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
So we provide a lot
of great helpers.
And so things that are something
that you would want to expect,
like an E in
someone's name, there
is a helper method
that could you.
And what's really nice
is it's very explicit,
where Google will
take over and go,
hey, do you want to
share this information?
And so it's all about
user privacy first.
And so we do have
some permissions
that you could use to
gather that information.
When it comes to the user's
name and their family name
and their photo
and their location,
not necessarily
precise location,
but it could be like
a zip code location.
And then, of course
account linking,
where you can build
that out and be
able to connect their
account to a database
that you might have as well.
So there's a lot of tons
of resources that could
support that functionality.
LUKE DAVIS: That's
super, super cool.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
LUKE DAVIS: So I am super
inspired by this thing
that you've built. How
long did it actually
take you to put
this thing together?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: It's
taken me a couple of weeks,
but that's also because I do
other things during the day.
And this was actually my
first action I had ever built,
so it took way longer because
I was struggling on some parts.
I'm like, this
doesn't make sense.
And that's when I
realized, I need
a design to follow and be
able to figure this out.
So I built this out, I would
say, in a couple of weeks
because it was still
all new and I was still
learning all the other
things, being new to Google
at that time.
LUKE DAVIS: So you didn't do
any kind of conversational voice
stuff before Google at all?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh, no.
No.
Well having conversations with
people, I do that all the time.
LUKE DAVIS: Which you're
really the best at, too.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And that's what
I think is really nice,
is that this space is not
where it's an expertise so
specialized that it's only
for a few people.
This is really something that
everybody, since we're born,
we learned how to
communicate with one another
and it's all about capturing
that and being able to code
it and see, does this work?
And it's still so new that
there is not a definite,
this is how all
actions should be.
Kind of like with
mobile or with web,
there is a sense
of best practices,
this is how things
should happen.
And users have an expectation
that, if I click on something,
it should go in the cart
and the cart's usually
on the right top corner.
There's certain things that
users are familiar with,
and with Voice, we're
still in this new space
that there's not that norm.
So this is a really
exciting time
to be able to get your hands
in and get dirty and try
to help mold what that would
look like in the future.
LUKE DAVIS: That
is super exciting.
I'm so glad that you
get to work on this.
You're such a joy to work with
and so inspiring in the stuff
that you work on.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Oh, thank you.
Gee, I appreciate it.
LUKE DAVIS: Is
there anything else
that you'd like to talk about,
maybe around the best practices
stuff?
I know we talked about
having these conversations
between a few people
before you get started
to get an example of
the kinds of things
that you might include
in your action.
Are there any other common
best practices for getting
started in the this new space?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
I usually suggest
people, who are really
excited about this,
is go on our Codelabs
and that way you
can learn about how to
build your first action,
and that back and forth.
And you build your first
round of conversation
on the first Codelab.
And then the second
one takes it further,
where you're having
multi-turn conversation.
And then the third one actually
talks more about best practices
and how you should
greet your user.
Because you don't want to have
it where every time you see me
I go, "Hi, Luke."
And like the next time you
see me I go, "Hi, Luke."
It doesn't feel natural.
So having that variety
within the conversation
is always nice too.
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah.
Yeah.
It feels like such a
different kind of thing to me
than the kind of mobile
or web development
that I've done in the past.
In a way, it kind of feels--
it feels inherently social.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh, yeah.
You couldn't just
necessarily, as a developer,
get this project
and be like, oh,
yeah I'm going to see you
guys in a couple days,
hide in a little nook
and code it by yourself.
LUKE DAVIS: Right.
Right.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
It's generally not
what you want to do.
Because you want to
share with other people
and with your designer and
get feedback and see like,
does this make sense?
And even when it comes to the
way you write the actual words,
you don't want something
that's too formal.
Because the way we write is very
formal, but the way we speak
is informal.
And so using the words,
"I will go to the store, "
is a little too formal.
Generally we say, "I'm
going to the store."
And so it's little things
that you don't notice it
until you hear it, and you
have other people hearing it,
and it's like, oh,
yeah, that sounds weird.
LUKE DAVIS: That's
really interesting.
OK.
So being able to have
varied responses, right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yes.
LUKE DAVIS: Doing this demo back
and forth, with actual humans,
beforehand.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
LUKE DAVIS: Keeping
humans in the loop
throughout the
development process,
to make sure that
it sounds natural,
using more informal language.
It sounds like you're
an expert on all this.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Well, I
have been spending a lot of time
with it, so.
And all this is, again,
in the Docs that we have.
And we have technical Docs
and we also have design Docs.
And so when you want to
just talk about design,
that I found to be really rich.
I'm like, oh, I never
thought about that.
How do you tell a user,
if you don't hear them,
it's not their fault that
we didn't hear them and?
And owning it as the
developer, like, I'm
sorry I didn't hear you,
versus say that again.
Like those little things,
I'm like, oh, yeah,
I never thought of that.
It's all there,
which is exciting.
LUKE DAVIS: Wow.
How long have you been
working on the platform?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: It's
been a year, recently.
LUKE DAVIS: Congratulations
on your Googleversary!
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Thanks.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Yeah, so it's still,
again, a new space.
So this is really exciting
because any developer could
kind of just jump on
right now and you'll
be part of the
first kind of wave
of people being able
to build for Voice.
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah.
That's super exciting.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
LUKE DAVIS: Oh, my gosh.
So do you have any
resources or references,
things that you would
like to encourage
other people to look at?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Oh, my first thing
I always recommend, Codelabs.
Go to the Codelabs, it's
Codelabs.Google.com.
That is the spot where you could
really onboard you onto it.
We have tons of videos as well.
LUKE DAVIS: OK.
Is there code somewhere
on the web, somewhere?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Totally.
Yeah, so on GitHub.
We have a GitHub rebuild
that has tons of samples,
and they're really great.
Whenever I start on a
project, that's usually--
if I have an idea
of what I want,
I like to go there and be like,
what's my boilerplate code.
And we also have Sample Actions,
which is this other idea that--
I know for me, if I'm
learning something,
the overhead of setup
could be daunting.
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And so there is a tool
that we built out
that will give you
a sample agent and
Dialogflow that showcases
different functionality.
And so there's one
that's that gives jokes.
And so it highlights SSML
with the audio, and like that,
how do you grab information
and back and forthness.
So instead of having
to build everything
from scratch, click
on this one button,
it generates it for you.
And you can play with it and
there's code already in there
that you could just copy,
paste, and put in your space
and be able to build off of
that, which is really exciting.
LUKE DAVIS: How cool.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
LUKE DAVIS: Thank you
so much for coming on
to chat with me today, Jessica.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Of
course, my pleasure.
LUKE DAVIS: If people want to
learn more about this software,
like follow along as the field
develops, what should they do?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh, my gosh.
So I usually recommend to
people, go on our Twitter,
we have actions on
Google Twitter account.
And if you want to communicate
with other developers that
are building
fractions on Google,
use the hashtag AoGDevs.
Let us know what your thoughts
are, what bill building,
and then you'll be able to
share within the community, too.
LUKE DAVIS: That's so great.
Thank you so much.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Thanks.
LUKE DAVIS: We hope
you liked today's show.
If you have any
comments, or want
to tell us what you'd like
to hear in future episodes,
you can leave a note in
the comments down below.
I've been Luke Davis,
chat with you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]